well for an analysis of the situation in
taiwan we're joined here in the studio
by retired air vice marshal
sean bell good to have you back in the
studio
sean this is day two isn't it of the
chinese military drills in the waters
around taiwan just bring us up to speed
what's the latest yeah day two biggest
military show of force in the region for
a long time over 100 chinese fighter
bombers have been involved over 10
chinese warships
interesting enough
originally there's a sort of agreement
between china and taiwan they'd have
this median line where the military
forces from each side wouldn't
transgress but china has been flooding
across that line with its aircraft and
its ships over the last uh 48 hours
originally there were six uh military
zones where china was operating it's
live firing around thai um taiwan now at
seven now well we understand it's now
seven uh another one out out to the east
they've also been chinese operating uh
drones around kinman islands which only
five miles away from the chinese
mainland there's been 11 ballistic
missiles launched by china into these
zones some of them flying across the top
of taiwan china's claimed all of those
who hit their targets but in reality
they're firing them into the sea so it's
very difficult to tell interestingly
they've also fired five ballistic
missiles into the japanese economic zone
which is quite provocative
and interestingly enough as well these
six zones a couple of them actually uh
are infringe on the territorial waters
of taiwan and therefore china is
conducting live exercises within
territorial waters of taiwan now if that
was to happen in any other nation in the
world that's incredibly provocative and
dangerous of course china just claims
it's their country for taiwan's
perspective at the moment they've been
operating their mirage 2000s and their
f5 jets in their air defense zone and
also deploying their their navy and
missile systems around the country now
we know that they the chinese were
displeased by the visit of nancy pelosi
um
if it's possible to uh and to understate
that um why are china doing this now
yeah as you say i mean this is lots of
posturing and very advanced rhetoric
chinese are actually threatening or
intimidating taiwan they've been doing
this for quite some time um clearly with
their long-term aim of assimilating
taiwan back to china it's also the
military activity is also a good
opportunity for taiwan to test its
military capabilities but also train
it's not often you get to train in a
joint environment airland and maritime
operating together in a complex
environment in what would be a very
difficult amphibious operation they've
also got the chance what because china's
military are threatening taiwan they're
able to see how taiwan responds taiwan
will turn on its radars it will have its
military deployed so china will be
watching all those movements of its
airland and maritime and that will all
inform chinese planning for the future
what's interesting as well though from a
outside taiwan this seventh zone of
military zone is out to the east well
away from taiwan um that is probably not
targeted at japan and even though those
missiles went in the japanese economic
zone in reality it's almost certainly a
key message to the united states because
okinawa is one of the military
establishments for america in the region
it's got 26 000 military folks there now
most of our military base in this
country have about 2 000. so over 10
times the size of our military bases and
enormous and of course you've got the
uss ronald reagan operating a
nuclear-powered carrier in the region as
well all of this is very high risk game
of poker at the moment with some really
great risks of miscalculation all right
well the only good news is that you're
here to keep us up to speed with all of
the developments uh throughout the day
uh sean bell thank you very much indeed